hello everyone and welcome back to binge
battle i am mark ellis and you're not
but you are here to celebrate one of the
great tv shows of all time you see way
back in 1975 a signal left new york city
went way up into outer space and came
back into everyone's tv sets around 11
30 p.m no it wasn't the coneheads or it
wasn't just the coneheads no this was a
signal that would change the history of
television comedy blockbuster filmmaking
and so much more forevermore we're of
course talking about saturday night live
or as the kids say now snl which has
just recently entered its 47th season so
all the way back in the day when
wolverines were eating fingertips up
until modern day when a kardashian had
some fun at the rest of their family's
expense in a monologue we're gonna be
celebrating the best the brightest and
debating who is the all-time goat in a
number of categories all around saturday
night live just think of the history of
television sketch comedy what it was
before and since if we don't have
saturday night live we probably don't
have programs like mad tv or the state
and we certainly don't have movies like
the blues brothers of wayne's world or
even movies that are ancillary related
to saturday night live like bridesmaids
beverly hills cop
black sheep to name a few well maybe we
should have gone tommy boy instead but
again this is why we're here to debate
our favorite things within the world of
saturday night live i am so excited to
welcome back to the show two of just my
all-time favorite humans good friends of
mine and very passionate saturday night
live fans who maybe entered it in
slightly different eras but they're here
with their opinions and they are fervent
nonetheless so coming in first as they
wanted to be known as age before beauty
it is ken knapsock you know him you love
him from such endeavors as force center
and the good people association he's
also a terrific stand-up comic and
sketch comedy performer can i said that
right they are comedy sketches not skits
correct if you say skit i'm walking out
of here yeah i thought we were here to
debate howard cosell's saturday night
live show which was a year prior or so
to snl i got the wrong show i'm out of
here no it certainly was and it's funny
bring up howard cosell because snl has
very few peers when it comes to how long
it's been on the air for the tonight
show and monday night football are
really the only ones that come to mind
and so when did you first enter snl it
was probably just referred to as
saturday night live back then when did
that first hit the ken knapsack lexicon
was it a friend recommending it to you
was it a particular sketch your gateway
into studio 8h oh man and you're right
when i remember when people started
calling snl i was like that's genius
shorten it with the letters uh yeah uh
for me was uh i think you all we all
kind of discovered the show every
generation around that junior high early
high school age where you're kind of
learning comedy learning style for me
that was late 80s uh the 15th season the
anniversary season which man back then
seemed like 15 years it was around then
i'd heard about it before been familiar
with a little bit i've seen some
sketches or something pop up and
remember this is pre-internet all those
type of things i think comedy central
was still ha at this time and you'd
watch uh you know billy crystal say you
look marvelous and you didn't i didn't
really know what that was it was it was
that that late 80s time period where i
jumped into it
all right and so ken is here and i've
known him a long time almost as long as
i've known of saturday night live and
joining him and debating him in at least
four rounds of epic snl category
contention is one of the co-creators and
hosts of the very successful world girls
endeavor and you can catch her regularly
on scn live amongst her many other
programs this is steph sabras steph
welcome back to binge battle we're so
happy to have you back in this world do
you refer to it have you ever referred
to it as saturday night live or have you
always known it as snl i've always known
it as snl but i am glad we're talking
about age and beauty to our timeless
beauties
of this century and i'm glad to be on
screen with both of you but always snl
unless we're staying live from new york
it's saturday night live
it's uh one of the more fun things to
exclaim when you're in new york even if
you have nothing to do with the
particular show that night so what was
your first experience with saturday
night live or snl was it a sketch was it
a particular performance that stood out
to you and you wanted to know more about
that person how did you first come
across this beloved show
well i was a young lad in the early
2000s my parents always had snl on and
this the 2000s was like the era of tina
fey and we also will ferrell so and that
was at the time of all the election
sketches so that's when i started being
like what is that i didn't really
understand it but it was funny to me and
then when i got in college my roommates
were equally obsessed with snl so we
would have these like quarterly snl
dinners where we would all show up in
character and ever since then it's just
been a staple i just love it so much
it's shaped who i am and i think so many
of us entertainers we wouldn't be doing
doing what we're doing without snl
uh however y'all are watching this
whatever device you're enjoying it with
we appreciate your eyeballs and we love
your comments after the fact whatever
app you're using whatever device you
enjoy watching us on let us know or you
can follow us all on social media and i
think steph's going to get a lot of
followers if you promise to post some of
the pictures of you and all your friends
from college dressed up in character is
that is that a deal we can make right
now it's an absolute deal it was killer
i'm not gonna lie we slayed it i will
post them okay and ken now i do have to
counter with you we have uh david s
pumpkin's favorite holiday is almost
upon us as we tape this so
have you ever been as an snl character
for halloween i have not but you
mentioned david as pumpkins that year i
was at disneyland and i had on a pumpkin
tie that was black with like orange
pumpkins like the suit that hexes wear
and someone
a young young lady jumped in front of
the line pointing me and went david has
pumpkins and ran off
i'll get to tom hanks fame
and ken has not worn the attire since so
we're gonna get kicked off here with
round number one of binge battle it is
here it is time to debate the latest and
greatest with saturday night live or snl
i still remember when kentucky fried
chicken was not kfc and i was like oh
that makes so much more sense now you
take out the fried it sounds healthy and
that's what we're here today for healthy
debate all the way around and we're
kicking off with round number one
funniest sketch what is the funniest
sketch we make it hard for the
competitors today of all the great
sketches that you've ever witnessed on
snl steph zabra one minute or less on
the clock what is the funniest sketch in
the history of the show
hardest question i've ever been asked
but i'll start by saying well lottie
freaking duh we're going in the van down
by the river because we can't talk about
snl without talking about chris farley
who is such an icon and you want to talk
about the funniest character in my
opinion that he's ever had is matt foley
uh you start this sketch with david
spade and christina applegate they're
getting in trouble for smoking the good
old devil's lettuce and then the parents
bring in this motivational speaker
matt foley which is how i feel every
motivational speaker should be like i
don't care about your accomplishments i
want to learn from your failures and
that's what he did in every single line
this man threw out was insane thrice
divorce living in a van down by the
river and then you throw that with the
physical comedy some of the best
physical comment you'll ever get on
screen you end this sketch with him
jumping accidentally on and breaking the
table this sketch was so funny to the
audience and to uh they had to cut
around phil hartman and julie sweeney
because they were laughing so hard and
it's like you knew greatness was on
screen when you can't you have two of
the greats can't you have to cut around
them so for those reasons and above and
down by the river forever and always
yeah two of the cast members who were
seemingly unbreakable at the time
helpless dandelions in the hands of
chris farley here's you here's matt
there's you there's ken with your
rebuttal not yet you just get your
minute opening statement no pressure
okay my opening statement yeah
i could probably fight for every of her
steph's answers as well as mine right
that's the the challenge of this debate
uh funniest sketch but also i'm gonna
list one of the more influential
sketches steph actually mentioned it
prior i'm going to the 2000 debate
sketches especially the first one and
this is something uh
snl and politics have been going strong
for a long time but this one has an
important legacy to it the words like
strategy
lock box daryl hammond's al gore will
fair farrell's uh george w bush and then
chris parnell's jim lehrer funny on
point poignant political satire that got
to the point where actual people in the
campaigns were studying these sketches
to see almost like what are we doing out
there how can we win this election what
are the people thinking about us that
had never really happened before uh you
know george herbert walker bush not dana
carvey was cute and roughed up his hair
once hey yeah you're right thousand
points of life uh dukakis in the debate
and i can't believe i'm losing this guy
we all remember that kind of stuff but
this one i actually think
helped influence the election model the
election however you want to look at it
this uh was also just so funny and and
and down to the the the lines the
pinpoint accuracy of the satire as well
as the parity of what was going on and
it is still the standard bearer for
political sketches going forward from
2000 on you're still trying to reach
this it's not just the candidates
thinking they're cute it's the
candidates going what is everyone saying
about me because i need to know
it is an underrated political influencer
when it comes to presidential elections
as far back as when people quote i was
told there would be no math i don't know
if they know that they're referencing
snl or politics but you're doing both
all right so we got two pretty great
sketches on the board the 2000 very uh i
don't want to say controversial but
let's just say it's a sketch that may
have changed some votes one way or the
other with the political debates and
then we also have of course the van down
by the river so steph now about 30
seconds for your rebuttal why is your
sketch and your van down by the river
better than a political debate
well we talked we're we were asked to
give the best sketch and ken has listed
sketches which leads me to believe that
i needed the whole facade to give the
punch even though i agree that it did
change the way that we have political
satire on screen even uh will ferrell
was quoted by saying that he
thinks that he may have swayed the
election by humanizing george bush and i
know that you both pointed that out but
we know how that ended so while it was
funny was it worth it
it's a great question posited by steph
there so ken your take on why this and
maybe politics in general on snl is
better than any one hilarious sketch
well look here's here's the thing i
absolutely love matt foley's a character
chris farley you could put chippendales
up there you could put a lot of his
sketches here uh
absolutely he deserves a spot but it is
also a great second city sketch that's
where it came up odenkirk helped write
him right and create the character over
there and some people actually seen it
before and that's not new with saturday
live let's be clear about that new cast
members do take some of their best
sketches from their previous places and
put them up here but you know what made
it was maybe the breaking of the
character and sometimes for me that
doesn't mean it was a great sketch just
means they got the cast members laughing
or the guest host laughing and that
becomes more memorable than the actual
content but i was laughing too okay yeah
it is a fair point that you bring up
where sometimes the breaking of the
character it's like ah you're kind of
subterfuging the sketch just a little
bit i didn't see it necessarily in this
one doing that but the point is taken so
now we'll go to the final statement for
each competitor then i really have the
hard job here you have to make a
decision between these two steph you're
up on the clock first
my final statement is that because of
this character
i think that we have reduced the number
of humans that are living in a van down
by the river and for that
you're a great patriot and we owe a lot
to this sketch
humans making better life decisions it's
a pretty tall mountain to scale ken what
do you got
look we we all know the right answer was
the nude beach sketch from 86 where
penis was said 43 times we just didn't
want to answer that one uh look uh matt
foley's great chris farley is a legend i
still look at the influence of the first
sketch which set the tone even the
sketches after we're trying to reach the
first sketch but that was a good
strategy uh steph to try to uh get me on
that technicality i think it is a like i
said a standard bear for sketches and
that's why it stands among the rest of
them
all right so now this is the toughest
part of the competition because i have
to make a decision between these two
brilliant answers the 2000 election
sketch or matt foley the motivational
speaker the topic was originally
funniest sketch and so here's how i see
this one going down is that saturday
night live is known for many things not
the least of which maybe most
importantly is that we can go there for
a safe place to laugh at politics
because we all know that regardless of
how you feel about politics there's a
lot of stress when it comes to that
arena and we need an outlet for it snl
has given us that and that is one of the
show's strongest legacies however if you
just sit me in front of a tv and you say
i'm gonna make you laugh harder than
you've ever laughed in your life for the
duration of one sketch
i think that anything with chris farley
is going to be way up there including
when he was playing rudy giuliani's son
but i'm going to take it a step further
and i'm going to say van down by the
river might be the play the way that it
is set up that he's been drinking coffee
in the basement for hours the way that
it pays off with some physical comedy
table breaking it really is just a one
of a kind because chris farley was one
of a kind and he made phil hartman enjoy
the sweeney break so
it's a great argument by ken but steph
cebrah gets the point here steph you are
we presume not living in a van down by
the river but those curtains i maybe i i
are you sure is it a camper no yes a
luxe camper i might just run through the
window just to show my appreciation to
chris farley's comedy
really
steph takes a 1-0 lead and maybe we'll
lean into a table later on in the show
but for right now can you find yourself
trailing by one as we head into round
number two
best sketch character you yourself have
been a lot of great sketch characters
over your years in comedy on snl what's
the best sketch character of all time
well not enough as i got voted out of
the system here uh let me tell you what
uh we're going back to 1992 for the big
year of it uh wayne campbell garth algar
wayne's world uh this is a sketch uh you
no you didn't just have to be there
experience it the legacy lives on one of
in fact these i think that the highest
profitable saturday night live movie is
the first wayne's world uh it it spawned
an entire uh you merch there's a book
there's uh there's like i said the movie
the the the sketch the history of the
sketch check one sibling sibilance i
heard that at a show the other day
people it all comes from that but
it was it was a rock and roll feel and
uh
when when you heard that uh aurora cable
10 presents you were at home and you you
and your friend started laughing you
didn't text you called you're doing a
wayne's world sketching and you quoted
it all through the next week and hope
they did it again it was to me a modern
template for what was coming so so much
that lorne michael saw it as that and
every other character they tried to make
a movie out of it it didn't quite work
nothing could capture what was going on
with wayne and garth which is why for
then now and hopefully forever they're
the best sketch characters of all time
on snl
all right wayne and garth are on the
board out of aurora illinois steph sabra
your minute is dedicated to which sketch
character
the best sketch character of all time
for me is debbie downer created by the
one and only rachel dratch because
first of all if you're not worried about
the increasing number of feline age
you're a monster
you're a monster but when we when we
debbie downer she created this term like
how we refer to tissue paper as kleenex
we refer to those horrible energy
sucking vampires that we all
know the dinner table with as a debbie
downer we use this in everyday language
and this originated from an snl sketch
that hasn't that doesn't happen very
often if ever like this is probably the
most famous just two-liner that you hear
so many times and people don't even
realize it originated from snl and from
rachel dratch herself and i just think
comedy is at its funniest when it's
relatable and that's why this character
is so hilarious because it is relatable
we know these people we want to punch
these people in the face and the only
way we can survive these people is by
laughing at them and that's exactly what
happened she broke the entire world
every time she appeared on screen
because you have to laugh at the
absurdity and the awfulness that is a
debbie downer and that's why she's the
greatest sketch character of all time
it's a pretty solid response because we
don't have this category today best
underrated cast member of all time but
if we did rachel dratch is right at the
top of my list so ken i'm gonna give you
five extra seconds because first i want
you to answer have you ever been a
debbie downer at a party and then you're
rebuttal to stepson that's a loaded
question because you know i am a debbie
downer and
now uh maybe that's why i don't like the
sketch no i actually love this sketching
i love rachel's stretch here but let me
tell you 2021 i was in lake arrowhead i
was out for a walk and there was a guy
walking with his dog and a car came and
he stepped out of the road and the car
drove by and then the guy said game on
and went back into the road with his dog
that's wayne's world there's two words
that have a great
schwing all those kind of things as if
not whatever you want to say it set the
bar back then uh once again steph loves
laughing because she loves when cast
members break other people which is not
rachel josh's fault for being one of the
funniest people on the planet uh but i
just think uh for what the entire
package was of what a best sketch
character idea the template for
everything that came forward like i'll
go get my wayne's world book from 1992.
i don't think there's a debbie downer
one maybe there should be but there
isn't that's why i stick with them
wayne's world certainly has etched its
way into the zeitgeist debbie downer has
two instead made some great points about
that so steph what is your counter to
ken's rebuttal why is debbie downer
standing head and shoulders for you
above wayne and garth
well ken i hate to bring up the same
argument but we were asked best sketch
character
and yours is characters plural uh
wayne's world was involved two
characters i know that it's a
discrepancy however it was hilarious i
love wayne's world mike myers is one of
the greatest of all time one of my
favorites of all time but when you talk
about the newer age the the
the 2000s were an important era for snl
resurgence and they really like stuck to
pop culture in a way that they hadn't
done in the prior years debbie downer
was one of those where she didn't find
pop culture to find a moment in pop
culture and it stayed consistent
throughout the years we're still quoting
it now it's
2021 and this was in the early 2000s
i'm feeling not only the love of these
characters from both you but i'm also
feeling how much they've shaped your
life because i feel like ken has modeled
a lot of his career after wayne and
garth and i feel like steph has modeled
a lot of her career after not being a
debbie downer
congratulations you both are rousing
successes at your various endeavors but
ken you have to limit all that history
that you have with these two
knuckleheads into a final statement uh
first of all you're right the 2000s were
resurgence there was an election sketch
in 2000 that helped
revitalize the show um no look i'm not
i'm never going to take anything away
from rachel dratch she's legitimately
one of my favorites and the technicality
again the producers accepted it this is
a dirty trick this is strategy again on
steph's part i'll just say this about
wayne and cam wayne campbell garth algar
they are an entire generation of of uh
our
fans they're their favorite characters
they were a movement they were a
lifestyle uh they influenced careers
they were the template and i think they
should be rewarded for being the
template for everything that came before
or came after and maybe even before
beautiful beautiful words from canon now
steph your final statement stumping for
debbie downer
wayne and garth are truly iconic however
when we're talking especially for me as
a female snl fan i'm looking for the big
hitter comedians who are women and
rachel dratch with this character is so
good at bringing she brings up points
that you hate to agree with if someone
told you at a table that they can't have
kids the conversation's over no fun is
to be had after that point and that is
just such a mic drop and she did that
every single time she appeared on screen
you just ended the screen it was like a
mini series each episode with the intro
and she just mic dropped with the worst
piece of news you could ever imagine and
somehow left you in a happier mood
i i just saw that particular sketch
you're talking about and i always say i
don't want kids at parties to lighten
the mood and maybe i'm having the
reverse effect i'm not sure
but this is such a tough call to make as
all these categories are going to be
today i feel like this and and and i
will accept wayne and garth as one
character as versus debbie downer
so i asked you all the top of the show
what was your gateway into snl for me it
was wayne and garth because i wasn't a
regular viewer of the show at that
period of time i might have been a
little too young i'm not sure but i
remember the kids at school talking
about this wayne's world movie that was
coming about and i saw the poster i'm
like who are i've never heard of these
guys saw the movie gateway back into
becoming a huge saturday night live fan
that i am today and so they were very
formative in my youth and in addition to
all the things that they have done for
movies and for merch they also helped a
little band called queen get to the back
of the top of the charts early in the
1990s
debbie downer is such an important
character because of the time period
that steph pointed out is that 2000's
where we were sort of still in a
hangover from the great cast and all the
eventual movie stars that we had gotten
in the early and mid 90s on saturday
night live so it was an important
statement to say no now we're here now
it's our time we're going to make some
memorable characters too so debbie
downer is an all-timer in my book as is
rachel dratch but wayne and garth were
an entire generation's voice in a way
that i don't think debbie downer ever
quite got to although
i'm going to keep an eye on this in the
coming months how many times i actually
think oh that person's a real debbie
downer because we know a few of them
we're not going to out them here but we
know a few of them in our world but i'm
giving the point to ken because of how
passionate he is about wayne and garth
and so look at this we're tied at one to
one after two rounds and if ken still
trying to fight for his round one is any
indication i don't think steph's getting
rid of her debbie downer love anytime
soon so we move on to now
we just had the best sketch character of
all time we're going to look at who's
playing them this is the round that
maybe is the best bar argument you could
ever get into
the best cast member in the history of
snl steps abroad you have before
this question gave me a headache but
then suddenly i woke up and the answer
was clear it has to be eddie murphy
eddie murphy came out of time when snl
was at its lowest viewership they were
on the chopping block people didn't know
what the future would be for it and
somehow eddie murphy showed up with some
of the most important and hilarious
characters we've ever seen buckwheat mr
robinson
velvet jones impressions of james brown
stevie wonder sketches white like me
which changed the way that we talk about
race and privilege in america and they
made it did it and he did it in the best
way most effective way in my opinion
which is to make us laugh while looking
at something that's quite disturbing if
you really look into it so without eddie
murphy we don't know where the future of
snl would have been and he reshaped the
new type of sketches that they were
doing the new type of characters and
jokes that they were willing to take and
in addition to that eddie murphy was one
of uh the most famous while actually on
snl which definitely garnered more
viewership and popularity by getting
those double takes between his movies
and snl appearances every single
saturday night
just full disclosure to everybody
watching right now it warms my heart
that stuff took eddie murphy because
i'm sure that all of us on screen right
now have had conversations about how
much we love eddie murphy and so ken i'm
just telling you right now the bar has
been set very high but i do believe in
you and your comedic prowess that by the
way i've seen steph in the audience when
you're on stage making people laugh and
so you do hold some sway here but it's a
tough argument to counter don't worry
about that yet just give us a nice
opening statement who you think is the
best cast member in saturday night live
history i'm not going to rebut yet but
this is a debate of star versus spine is
what it comes down to uh everything
steph has said is 100 right about eddie
murphy i looked at this from the other
angle of the best cast member uh and
cast cast not one star but cast and that
to me has got to be the man who had the
nickname glue which is phil hartman from
uh the the 86 to a 93 era over 70
characters he had the ability to be a
star character a catchphrase character
unfrozen caveman lawyer anal retentive
chef uh the old-time movie star guy what
do you say and tell me the truth with
lovett but he also you mentioned the
matt foley sketch he was the straight
man the father he was one who lifted
everyone else up whether it was helping
jan hooks with her stage fright behind
the scenes was helping to usher in a new
era of snl which ends up not being one
of my favorite eras but he he was he was
a mentor for a lot of those folks and
and his tragic loss not factoring that
in this conversation was felt among so
many people he was there to help start a
new era he was there to help build the
era after and all the way through he was
the absolute backbone of the show again
i use that word a lot a template of what
they kind of needed and looked for uh
eddie murphy starr phil hartman spine of
the show that's why he's my choice for
best cast member
and that is how you give an opening
argument kids uh by the way our nickname
for our
great celebrated director here at
christian vue vocab is in fact glue so
hi glue thanks for making us look good
all right steph back to you for a
rebuttal now why is eddie murphy better
than phil hartman i feel like it's
sacrilege to even ask it i it really is
it makes me kind of stick to my stomach
that i have to give this argument but i
will because phil hartman is one of the
greatest to ever do it um r.i.p truly
legendary work but would that legendary
work have been on screen if it wasn't
for eddie murphy researching the
popularity in snl we really don't know
how snl would have played out what the
future of phil hartman would have been
on snl if it wasn't for eddie murphy
invigorating american viewership on snl
so and when we talk about what the heart
and soul of snl is yes it is the way
that they uh he did have the nickname
glue but
we're we remember the sketches we
remember the characters and i think that
eddie murphy has some of the most if not
the most number of iconic characters and
impressions that we've ever gone on snl
so for that reason i think eddie murphy
has to take the crown
okay ken i'm gonna tennis it back to you
again everybody watching this is just my
job i'm torn i feel like the mom at the
end of the movie the good son right now
i don't want to drop either one off the
ledge phil hartman eddie murphy ken
you're taking phil hartman why
look eddie's electric eddie is a star
and he did save the show there's no
debating that the gene dominion era was
gonna sink the show uh they took some
big swings it didn't work out right but
when he left and he became such a big
star he kind of had to leave right 48
hours all the stuff going on there was
nothing left on the bone there was great
cast members tim kazarinsky one of my
friends julie louis dreyfus gary kroger
brad hall all these names that uh you
know had some talent attached to him but
they didn't get a chance to shine uh and
and so when he left there the the show
fell apart again and when lauren
michael's returned and had one really
bad season 85 86 the show was on the
chopping block again they needed to do
something else and it was phil hartman
that was brought in from the ground
lanes late he was in his late 30s when
he comes in here and again helps build
up the show and at times in the early
90s it struggles again but it never
really got to that pure chopping block
point like it did after the 85 86 season
which uh it was post eddy so it was a
repeating cycle then but uh hartman
comes in here and just wows everyone
with his talent his skill and his
mentorship
if you get ken knapslock sleepy enough
when he's talking about this stuff he
really confuses snl with baseball
because both the seasons sound 85 86 86
87 but
batting average 500 is that the year
terry sweeney played second base for the
eggs i think it was
we got him off track surprise got him
right where she wants him steph back to
you for your final statement on the
greatness celebrating eddie murphy
well i think when comedy is its
strongest and most powerful mark you
pointed this out earlier is when we can
have hard political discussions and
discussions about race and privilege and
eddie murphy is one of those people who
just by design by his life how he's
lived who he is and being a black
comedian especially at this time he was
able to bring up topics that other
people could not bring to the forefront
so i you just have to think mr white
showed us a world that uh many black
americans have been trying to show us
how whites live for a long time and we
are forever grateful for that that's
like flipping the entire lens the way
americans viewed uh in existence
and in a funny way and no one else could
do it like eddie murphy
that's that's the clip out of the show
right there no one else could do it like
eddie murphy but phil hartman like ken
you said he was the spine where eddie
was the star so you have one more
statement to support the late great phil
hartman i want to acknowledge steph
that's right i was a young
white uh kid in suburbia who saw that
sketch and went oh i see something now
yeah steph's right about that absolutely
and eddie is superstar i just uh always
look at phil the warmth of his
characters the uh getting to the heart
of all of us um getting uh you know the
clinton stuff was fun that's the
headline stuff but phil's ability to
lift everyone else up with him uh was uh
his lasting legacy uh and i just think
of that last moment with him and farley
on stage as they sing as the show fades
away and what an angelic moment that
ended up unfortunately being for both of
them but it speaks to the warmth of the
soul phil hartman he was the soul of a
show that uh absolutely needed one
following the uh uproarious mid 80s
i was going to bring that up too is is
that nice little sweet moment that we
got with phil hartman and chris farley
saying goodbye to the show after so many
great years and great runs and we don't
want to have to remember them we want
them still here on earth like with eddie
murphy but if we had to let them fly to
the next chapter that's a pretty nice
way to remember them but phil hartman
also you can see how much every cast
member loved working with him because he
popped up in so many movies during and
after his snl run just because everybody
loved working with him they knew he
could be the glue on a big time movie
set as well as with a very fast-paced
frenetic sketch show that was going week
after week after week and i love what
you said about him being the spine where
eddie was the star
but as i've told you and anybody else
who will hear within earshot that eddie
became the star and he was also the
spine of that show in the early 80s
because as really both you pointed out
that show
was going to be toast it was on the
verge of being canceled and phil hartman
was part of a cast that saw a monster
much-needed resurgence or else we're not
talking about saturday night live in
terms of it's still running but eddie
murphy was the first person to step up
to the plate and almost almost
single-handedly put that show on his
back like atlas and carried it through a
number of seasons he was the reason that
you tuned in and it's one of the very
few times in the history of any program
you could say i'm watching it more for
this particular individual than i am the
name brand of the show and so whereas
phil hartman gets all the roses i could
possibly throw his way in my book the
reason why we still get to enjoy
saturday night live today
is most thanks still to the comet that
hit in the early 1980s that being
the incredible eddie murphy so eddie
murphy gets the point here but god you
all really are
giving me stress
this is the hardest it was so hard
i mean i think
yeah i think i was drunk in new york
recently we said i think the answer is
eddie murphy and then uh you know i hear
i am talking about the wonderful phil
hartman you could go either
but but it is a great point you bring up
because again phil hartman may be the
the principal reason of that new cast
why the show continued to run and run so
well afterwards and so there's a lot of
savings of the show but also don't
forget that eddie murphy simply carried
the show for a couple years just think
about the initial not ready for
primetime player cast that he had to
follow stepping into those
huge footprints so eddie murphy won for
the ages as is phil hartman but as it
stands today our scoreboard is two to
one in favor of steph cebrah and so the
world girl can give winning a world here
today if she gets one more category
correct but standing in her way is just
a juggernaut of sketch comedy love and
that is 10 knapsacks who can you get the
opening salvo as we head into round four
the best generation
group the best generation group of snl
we talked about great sketch characters
great cast members but now it's the team
as a whole what's the best locker room
era of all time
yeah studio weight age yeah look uh i
could probably i might have voted for
steph every round that's how great her
answers are and great explaining here um
there's a lot of wonderful errors of the
show and the original cast era uh is
what it is it's legendary i love the
acting chops of the 2006 7 to 2012 range
with people like uh kristen wiig and
jason sidekick as bill hater but i go
again and i realize all my answers seem
to be from the same area it's not just
because i was in junior high then i
really looked at it and you kind of
touched it upon a mark i touched the
phone the show was gonna go away again
they convinced michaels to come back and
then that didn't even work he needed to
go all the way back to the beginning and
build it back up and dana carvey noradon
phil hartman jan hooks vittoria jackson
john lovetts dennis miller kevin nealon
is a feature player then eventually rep
a whitney brown al franken and then many
more that came and i'm looking at the 86
to like 92 era now i'll say this first
and i i will concede this point to steph
the biggest problem with it up top was
it was not diverse this was i think
directly led to a show like in living
color coming to existence which i'm
thankful for but it shouldn't it didn't
have to snl should have been more
diverse a lot early that's a problem
with this cast that i get i need to
concede that up top but talking about
what this show did this was dana carvey
as a superstar mike myers comes in in 89
uh becomes a superstar chris rock adam
sandler a little bit later on but at the
end chris farley 1990 tim meadows
another kind of glue-like cast member it
was again one of those tempted things
but also the modern era of films
characters merch all that kind of stuff
did not exist until dana carvey church
lady you know we didn't have a film but
wayne wayne and garth we talked about
that uh sketches like tunzes hans and
franz all those kind of things became
true water cooler talk for the next
generation that already been looking at
the original cast as titans but also
history also something you watched in
reruns this the 15th season and beyond
really reignited the show it put lord
michaels back into a little bit more
control of the show he helped create uh
when he needed to save it again uh it
set the template for a lot of things i
always go to that i know but it's very
important you talk about the best dennis
miller's a weekend update anchor that's
how you were supposed to do it dana
carvey is a superstar build everyone
else that's what you're supposed to do
you need a utility superstar like
hartman you got jan hooks one of the
more underrated uh compet uh performers
on the show norah dunn great actor great
actor coming their sweeney sister sketch
funny stuff uh you're a fan of the show
is what you're saying
fan of the show i'll wrap it up do i get
13 minutes no i can't believe it
um
it was a rock star era without the
rockstar attitude it's okay if our
comedians hear jog the light a little
bit because of the passion and the
ferocity with which you love this 86 to
92 era it did inspire a lot of water
core talking it also made whoever was
sitting closest to the copy machine at
work the most annoying person at your
job
beth sabra your era countering 1986-1992
what's your answer for the best cast era
well i'll say this can i could listen to
you talk all day long you're a killer
and i i it's hard to argue with you but
i want to take everyone to a time in
american history that was quite sad this
is post 9 11. america had shifted we had
become a more depressed country than we
had seen in the prior decades i could
argue
and what did we need comedy and how did
we do it by having the first female head
writer in snl history i'm talking about
tina fey a household name that you hear
every single day and what her mark on
snl shifted the way that snl did
sketches like i said earlier this is
when we really started getting into pop
culture and they started to focus on
that in a way and then you want to just
talk about the cast that they had
probably one of the most star-filled
casts inside snl and outside snl you had
the tail end of will ferrell's snl
career the last two years possibly his
best two years on snl arguably jimmy
fallon tracy morgan maya rudolph horatio
sans amy poehler rachel dratz chris
parnell fred armisen daryl hammond will
forte these are people that you see and
love every day to this day but it all
started in their early 2000s on snl they
had some of the most iconic sketches
that i think in the youtube generation
my generation growing up probably have
the most views viewership because that's
when we got to see it and i'm not saying
that that makes them better sketches but
i think it makes it a little bit more
impactful in terms of how we view snl to
this day so for that reason so much came
out of that including debbie downer and
so many other great sketches so this
this was my era this is a top dog era
for me
i see what both y'all are doing by the
way i i see every one of y'all with your
answers reminding me that i might have
made a mistake in ruling one way or the
other in previous rounds so
it props to both of you for doing that
you're also talking to my heartstrings
here because steph you talk about how
needed a great cast was post 9 11 where
we all wanted to go somewhere to laugh
but then can you also talk about 86 to
92 the tail end of that was when i
started to come into my own and say you
know what i might never be a
professional athlete probably going
gonna have to give this funny thing a
shot so you have the first shot at a
very tough rebuttal but i think you're
up to the task again and it's just 30
seconds ish so if you want to jog
i'll get a good twerk going yeah i'll
take the time note um here's the thought
um
after that era 92 93 it became a a a
horrible boys club satellites always
struggled with that but the mid 90s the
show fell apart again and that's when
they needed it and realized in 96 97
they needed to get back to what they had
a true ensemble build stars out of that
uh and that is what that 86 cast did as
well and just some absolute legends it's
not dana carvey's fault that opportunity
knocks wasn't on youtube first all right
that's just a thing of the era and and i
was there opening night one of the
greatest moments of my life uh my life
uh there you go that's why i like 86 era
all right and steph your counter once
again to why the post 911 will say the
early 2000s to the late 80s very early
90s is better
i'm gonna use my water bottle and my
lipstick to demonstrate a cowbell also
one of the greatest sketches of all time
also came out of this era never forget
more freaking cowbell you can never have
enough cowbell that's just one of the
many sketches that came out of this era
we also had tina fey and amy poehler the
first time two women co-anchored wink at
an update in my favorite sector of
weekend update ever to be had so this is
why
chopping broccoli can your final
statement as to why the late 80s early
90s
reigns supreme-ish
with snl my final statement is i love
the era stuff talking about it's amazing
it's absolutely amazing you won't give
it the point i understand
but go back to that era go back to
carvey myers kneeling news from 10 feet
away i don't care what you think about
dennis miller now but back then he was a
rock star on the weekend update desk it
was an amazing electric era and i
absolutely love it
and maybe the the funniest line from
that era was dennis miller welcoming
chris farley to the show by saying did i
just see the new guys
so
with that we go back to steph for your
final argument early 2000's is the best
why
i see what you're doing here ken and i i
ca i wouldn't blame you either mark if
you went with ken's groups it is it is
such an incredible era i agree with it
but i i really think that what tina fey
did is historic and you just
we talk about how snl a lot of times was
a boys club and when she came into the
scene she not only just proved that
women are funny and they're not women
comedians they're just freaking
comedians and then that ushered in a
whole new era where the names that come
to mind now are kristen wiig maya
rudolph amy poehler this changed the
landscape of comedy for women and the
way we view comedy as a greater whole as
a people and we can actually view women
with brains that can be funny and not
just faces
and i think i brought up bridesmaids at
the top of the show just because you
have so many people that were sort of
developing their careers at saturday
night live and like you said tina fey
being the head writer there was such a
landmark shift and such a quality one so
we have the current host of the tonight
show jimmy fallon from that era and we
have for my money the best award show
host that money can buy much better than
the guy talking right now amy poehler
and tina fey i'd love to see them walk
on any stage and host and so you pinned
that against the late 80s early 90s
where you have some of the biggest
blockbuster stars still to this day in
movie history emerging from there but
what did they actually do on the show
and this is i think where i'm ruling
this
most prominently is that the biggest
difference that i see besides how much
more progressive and necessarily so that
the early 2000s was was that steph made
a great job in pointing out that this
was post 9 11 and snl saw a huge bump in
rating simply because we needed
somewhere to go
to laugh at a crucial turning point in
american history by contrast
we weren't going to saturday night live
anymore for laughs for whatever the 80s
were throwing at us by that point in
time for the most part with snl and it
wasn't a
event that happened in america that made
us come back it was simply the quality
of the cast that was put together once
lauren michaels was firmly back in
charge of snl and so whereas we knew we
could go to snl for laughs versus we
never thought we would be going back to
snl for laughs again that's why i think
the late 80s might have been a little
more important just in terms of the show
culturally i completely agree with staff
that we were so in need of what we got
in the early 2000s but in terms of the
show itself and also because i'm a very
selfish host and i want to see a
tiebreaker around here i'm giving the
point to ken it is two to two as we get
into
sudden death overtime it's not really
sudden death because you each get you
know hey nfl are you taking notes each
team gets the ball and has a chance to
score a touchdown and then i'm gonna
make a ruling so you each get a minute
for round five and then we're done
there's no final statement there's no
rebuttal it's just you each get your
moment and then
once again i have all the pressure
heaped upon my shoulders which are not
nearly as mighty as eddie murphy's or
phil hartman's so
it's two to two steph you had a lead
it's now a tie so you get to kick us off
here in the overtime sudden death round
it's a tiebreaker and the topic is the
best
recurring host
in the history of snl there's been a lot
of great one-offs over the years there's
been so many great stars from every
corner of entertainment of sports
whatever you want to throw music
whatever you want to throw at snl they
can make it funny but in the history of
the program 47 years running now who is
the best recurring host minute on the
clock
a lot of people think that tom hanks is
america's dad but i happen to think it's
steve martin steve martin you can't have
in a conversation with snl and not put
the two and two together steve martin
was there from the inaugural season of
snl he is integrated in the very core
and existence of snl and that's why he
is to me the best reoccurring host he
has some of the best sketches he brought
out some of the best uh performances
from the cast members we know and love
two wild and crazy guys i'll never
forget to name a few king tut was one of
them the uh and he just had so many and
not only that was he great in the
sketches he was great at hosting it some
of his monologues were my favorite
monologues of all time and you never got
sick of steve martin and we still never
get sick of steve martin any time he
appears on screen we love seeing steve
martin because he just brings out the
heart and soul of what snl stands for
it's a it it's not all that spicy of a
take as it turns out ken because there
is a chance steve martin is america's
dad over tom hank i i don't know that's
that's a debate for another day but
steph just gave me something to wrestle
around in my brain the rest of the
afternoon your answer ken and your
counter to steve martin for the best
recurring host in saturday night live
history is
my answer is alec baldwin and i cannot
morally argue against steve martin
because steve martin's the reason i'm
here he's a big icon in my comedy life
so i'll just say this about alec baldwin
uh april 21st 1990 b-52 is a musical
guest alec baldwin the host he was a
movie star a heartthrob a good-looking
leading man and he shows up to promote a
movie and starts to slowly change the
course and trajectory of his career when
the movies are up and going he's
fighting a bear with anthony hopkins or
whatever the hell he's doing out there
he started to develop this other side of
his queer's personality and worked so
well with every single cast whether it
was kind of the mid 90s uh sandler era
whether it was the smarter uh tina fey
led era whether it was uh the the
wonderful kind of bold
viral ready for viral video a late 2010
uh era and then he eventually almost
becomes an essentially a cast member
with the trump stuff but it all began
when he showed up and surprised everyone
with his ability to
go from leading man to comedy cast
member uh ensemble host
of snl he it was no longer about him it
was about the show they were putting
together that's why alec baldwin is my
answer
i love that of all the movies that you
could have pulled out that alec baldwin
might have been there to promote you
pulled the edge starring i believe elle
mcpherson also makes a cat and a great
performance by a bear in there what
movie was alec baldwin promoting the
very first time was it miami blues do
you remember i cannot remember that i
mean it was uh not too far from
beetlejuice but uh that's uh i don't
know that uh movie released enough
beetlejuice was 88 and so i think it was
probably past then but i mean the the
filmography of al baldwin and steve
martin is a great debate that we could
actually have for another day but for
right now
steve marners is alec baldwin i mean
these really are the two goats right
when we talk about recurring hosts
there's others like tom hanks that have
made their mark there's been great cast
members that have been welcomed back to
the show sensitive made their mark as a
host now
peyton manning is great michael jordan
had some great moments so there's so
many great stars
but if we're doing steve martin versus
alec baldwin i feel like
i could go canteen boy or i could go
king tut but i think the tiebreaker in
the tiebreaker round is this when you
get into a conversation about our third
round who's the best cast member of all
time a lot of times people inadvertently
say steve martin even though he was
never an actual cast member that's how
seamlessly steve martin was integrated
into the show albeit at the time
initially when he was the biggest
stand-up comic in the world
selling out stadiums
and then he got so big the blues
brothers also an snl creation opened for
him right down the road from us at the
la forum and so while alec baldwin has
given us so many chuckles and memories
and ken does make a great point that he
basically kept hanging out of the show
and was so brilliant as trump in this
most recent run
if you go back and you look at the
all-time best recurring host steve
martin had the leg up from the start on
alcohol because he'd been doing it for
14 years more than alec baldwin had when
he first arrived but i still have to
give it to the og and maybe america's
stepdad if nothing else steve martin
gets the win and by proxy steph cebrah
gets the win today ken
i i i would love to take you out to a
friend's lunch at our favorite place
wood ranch if you'll if you'll allow it
i know it breaks my heart to make this
decision so i'm gonna apologize to ken
first look the greatest monologue of all
time is not gonna phone it in tonight
that is steve martin uh that is the
greatest model of all time steph
well steph congratulations thank you
maybe we can do a remix of two wild and
crazy guys featuring you two and
there'll be two wild and crazy guys and
a girl and then i'll just come in as
like the new debbie downer
that would be that would be great if ken
and i are just having a ball with our
ridiculous costumes and then debbie
downer's death comes
see we're making more comedy gold on the
program already so steph sabra is your
champion today but really the winner is
everybody who just got to watch a walk
down memory lane but we're not done here
as far as snl goes because it's been a
great kickoff to season
47. we all were so young and so i don't
think the show is losing any steam
anytime soon but not enough love for
bill murray come on bill murray is is
he's he's my america's dad so bill
murray we'll give you more love next
time we love you you're welcome to come
stalk us at any bar or watering hole or
wash the dishes at my place whatever you
want to do i know you love random stuff
have at it my friend so right now steph
sabra we get to talk to you first as our
winner here today what is a streaming
recommendation that you have for all the
kids watching out there that doesn't
have to harken back to snl in any
meaningful way but just something that
you think everybody who might have
enjoyed today's episode should check out
in the future
i think if you're a fan of lonely island
or anything that they did then you
absolutely have to check out dave on fx
it is with lil dicky one of the funniest
most poignant shows that i've seen and
it talks about topics of mental illness
in a way that is so good while being
funny and then also insecure final
season dropping and that is one of the
greatest shows issa rae is just a
comedy writing legend
insecure continued to break my heart
with every twist and turn of that
somewhat doomed relationship but you're
still rooting for it and dave is a is a
tremendous show and a tremendous comic
ander santino featured in that cast ken
you're here you're hanging around you're
a good sport you're a great competitor
and you are a wealth of knowledge when
it comes to really the history of sketch
tv in general snl included so what is
the streaming recommendation that you
have for everybody out there watching
today i'm going to sneak in a second
choice sorry producers uh i do want to
mention i am and this is why you made
the right decision with that steve
martin uh choice only murders in the
building i'm absolutely enjoying i'm
loving it steve martin martin george
selena gomez by the way it's a great
generational marker if you're like hey
you watched the new steve martin show do
you mean the selena gomez show
it's a wonderful show and it is it got
the heart that steve brings to a lot of
things can't recommend that enough the
other thing that now it's now available
out there i think on amazon prime uh all
five season uh seasons of kids in the
hall as they get ready for their big
reunion uh the the comeback show kids in
the hall as another great in comedy
influence on me uh mckenney and bruce
mccullough mark mckinnon bruce
mccullough wrote for the show in 85 86
mckinney comes back to be a cast member
in the mid 90s uh and uh love everything
about them scott thompson kevin mcdonald
uh and the rest of the gang there dave
foley just love them check out kids in
the hall if you haven't had a chance to
yet
and you go all the way back to sctv and
how many stars that gave us and so
there's just so much great sketch comedy
out there to enjoy if you're a stand-up
fan then you can actually see some guy
let me read this card right can knapsack
i haven't heard of it he's going to be
performing alongside me in washington
d.c almost at christmas time december 16
through 19 and get your tickets at mark
ellis dot live and that is going to be a
hoot a hoot nanny and we'll be two wild
and crazy guys that night we'll send you
facetime stuff uh that is your winner
steph sabra you can follow her on social
media at steph sabra that is ken
knapsock and you can follow him on
social media at ken knapsock they made
it easy for you i just had to put an
extra word in mind at mark ellis live
where you can find me for the great team
here at rotten tomatoes our engineer
slash director christian brubalcaba
steph and ken i am merely mark ellis
saying thank you and good night from new
york or l.a
bring it on